what up reject nation today we are gonna
check out the stranger things four
trailer but before we jump into that big
thank you to today's video sponsor
creeps unfortunately two out of three
guys will experience some form of hair
loss by the age of 35 which means in a
few years john's good looks will be gone
luckily keeps is here to help you
improve growth and even stop hair loss
with their clinically proven treatments
they'll put you in touch with their
expert team of medical advisors and
specialists to devise the perfect care
regimen delivered straight to your door
so you don't miss a beat each treatment
comes with a full year of unlimited
messaging with your prescribing doctor
so you can keep them posted ask
questions in real time even if you're
still to take better care of your hair
it keeps it hard hair loss stops with
keeps and to get 50 off your first order
go to keeps.com real rejects or click
the link in the description that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash real rejects
thanks again for sponsoring this video
now let's swing into this
you've broken everything
was that robert england probably
it's his house
billy
so sexy dear billy
i don't know if you can even hear this
oh he can
upside down
ever since he left everything's been
a total disaster
for a while we tried to be happy
[Music]
normal
there's no normal for you guys it's
impossible
cool
house with a clock and it's walls
[Music]
i relocated you guys far from hawkins
because i thought he'd be safe
stamps are the new clue
is that a package from russia with love
it's coming
i'm afraid your friends at hawkins are
very much
it's paul ryzer's voice
i don't have my powers
i don't know how to say this other than
just to say it
we need you without you
we can't win this war
hello
oh damn
demobats
on the other side
[Music]
what the hell going on there like a
demogorgon prison fight
people say hawkins is close
whoa
whoa
what the hell robert england yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
like some resident evil [ __ ] you
have lost
wow
is that
who robert england's play
i mean there's at least one image of him
as like a regular guy with his eyes
gouged out but it almost seems like
maybe there is like an upside down
equivalent of him or something i mean
you've got to keep up with the annie
from demogorgon to mind flare to now
whatever hellraiser
guy
i mean they did say they're going more
overtly horror this season so i mean i
wouldn't be surprised and to cast an
icon of horror like robert england and i
mean you know it's only the first time
i've seen that image but there's a
little bit of you know a freddy
reminiscence in that face there at least
i'm not sure what to make of that the
way how the last trailer made it look
with the creel house he is a victim of a
circumstance where he was framed for a
murder that wasn't actually his
responsibility but probably perhaps some
creature from the upside down that
murdered his family the things that you
see with these creatures
especially in like season three is often
the hybrids of like upside down entity
and human hybrid and then maybe the key
to them obtaining ultimate power
is the perfect hybrid and maybe that's
what he is i have no idea i i really
have no clue but this looks like the
most expansive out of any season like
you are like out of hawkins for so much
of this you're in california russia and
so much of the upside down and it looks
so horrific and there were like little
glimpses that we got throughout i re
finished my re-watch of stranger things
like like a couple weeks ago i want to
say well it has me curious of what
thematically what this season is going
to be because the first season was so
much about like trauma being inflicted
and fears and anxieties and such growing
as a person based off of those and the
second season dealt so much with ptsd
and the third season was all about
moving forward or learning to move
forward here this season seems to be
about in that path of moving forward
when your past catches up with you how
do you deal with that
you know which is such a part of life so
i feel like the first three seasons
thematically are perfectly complemented
yeah it starts off at the very top with
we're trying to have a normal life you
see that lucas is on the basketball team
and then levin is going to school i
wonder if she has a different name other
than 11 and she's trying to be normal
and her hair looks exactly like joyce's
or something he's not going by jane now
is she maybe yeah that's right about it
make more sense she's probably like
learning to accept her past actually you
know what that guy that might be billy
oh yeah hey that's also a good call yeah
yeah yeah cause it definitely i mean
like the upside down infects everybody
but it seems like it especially took
over billy's mind and body although i
don't know maybe because i feel like
sometimes stranger things they try to
mislead you with their marketing right
he had certain images here where like
max at one point were at the same scene
at the cemetery it seems that they're
going to comfort her but then her
herself starts to levitate i'm not sure
if these scenes with 11 are purely
flashbacks to uncover things because so
much of her was about escaping her past
and not wanting to relive and it's such
a triggering event for her to be
reminded of things like the rainbow room
and such wonder if they if it is like
present day and then bring her and then
bring her back to it because you know
there's a lot of theories that dr
bretter will be back this season not
just in the form of flashbacks because
we didn't actually see him die in the
first season if it's an off-camera death
it doesn't count they are still alive he
got attacked by demogorgon but we didn't
see his body so he might still be alive
still on the table and then of course
like with hopper and russia it seems
that he might
bond with some of the prisoners actually
in like an attempt to it seems like
they're going to escape at one point and
then they have to take out the
demigorgon themselves at least it would
look like at that one scene either that
or they're doing like some kind of
twisted like gladiator fights with like
the prisoners and demogorgons or
something but either way it looks like
hopper might be instrumental in i don't
know yeah helping to save some of those
guys or at least you know being the one
to
show everybody that they don't know what
they're dealing with what they have on
their hands here well this is also going
to probably deal with time travel if i'm
not mistaken or maybe not time travel
but some type of dimensional because i
don't feel like
you know you do see murray and joyce at
one point in a plane and it looks like
they're probably trying to rescue hopper
you know you got those clues in there
from the stamps there's maybe there are
these clues like she's receiving from
hopper that maybe he's still alive so i
they're probably trying to go rescue him
or he finds some type of gateway that he
gets him back to hawkins or something
maybe there's some kind of rabbit hole
within the upside down that connects
places where they shouldn't connect or
something like that and it's also going
to probably be like it looks like heavy
metal i was just guessing it's going to
be
tone and beam of this yeah heavy metal
aesthetics of like everybody getting a
little older and discovering rebellious
music and i don't know how that bit on
top of the bus with the electric guitar
in the upside down is gonna play out
that looks like one of the more broad
things and i feel like the seasons get
broader as they go and that is something
that while i'm wary in the sense that i
don't want to get too cartoony and i
feel like you could argue that season
three does broach that i am i'm very
excited to see what heavy metal does to
all these kids and everybody around them
in hawkins in california wherever else i
have a strong feeling that paul reiser's
probably gonna die in this season just
based off the way this trade i imagine
that maybe even volume one his carrot
that's when his character will die and
then of course with eleven maybe so much
of this is about her learning to ex
truly come to terms with her past
because i don't feel like she ever
really has here with her losing her
powers off of the end of season three
dealing with bullying while being at a
brand new school you know like going
from small town to california and
dealing with what the society is like
over there and then literally being
pulled back into this whole world and
then with her they actually need her
whereas a poor look like she was you
know someone who was a prisoner even
though she's they're putting her into
prison transport and stuff but they're
actually asking for her help and so
she'll need to like find her powers from
within again and maybe she'll come back
even stronger than before yeah i think
that matches what you said about this
sort of idea that you can't and
necessarily leave your past behind and
maybe for 11 it's going to be a sort of
arc where it's that she is connected to
this war as they're calling it now no
matter what these things that are
breaking through the upside down in this
whole situation that has come of
ill-fated government experiments as
unfair and terrible as that is maybe
yeah it's that she is connected to it
and if she can access herself from a
place of power maybe she is the only key
to stopping it or something like that
all right guys well stranger things
season four are you guys excited this
looks like an epic ass season they said
it'd be the biggest and you could tell
it'll be the biggest what do you guys
think leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button thanks to keeps for sponsoring
this video last but not least
deontay w tongue punch fart box now when
i think of a demogorgon who do i think
at our patreon page most resembles what
a demogorgon looks like it's definitely
a tongue punch fart box it has that and
yeah
and that it just looks do i need to
really explain in depth what a tongue
punch fart box ought to look like or if
there's any way you could defeat a
demogorgon it wouldn't be with some
steve harrington baseball bat or some 11
powers no the only thing that could take
down endemic organ is the equal and
opposite power which is a tongue punch
fart so either way you're most suited
for this
thanks thanks for being here deante
you're good man
[Music]